it's officially week eight of google
cloud next on air which means we're
focusing on cloud ai
i'm randy meyer and welcome to this week
in cloud where we're taking a sneak peek
at this week's content
week 8 is all about cloud ai meaning we
want you to see how ai can help everyone
on your team
there's all kinds of talks this week
that cover everything from
infrastructure to train ai and ml
projects
all the way to managed offerings that
give you the benefits of ml without
having to train your own models
so check out all the talks this week and
add interesting sessions to your
playlist so you can watch them
on demand speaking of managed offerings
this week we're shining the spotlight on
measuring and improving speech-to-text
accuracy
while the speech-to-text api is already
great out of the box
you may have custom needs for your
industry or use case
so this talk walks you through how you
can customize your model
improve accuracy and even features a lab
where you can try it out for yourself
one session i'm super excited for is
interpreting ml models with explainable
ai
no matter what the accuracy of your ml
model it can be hard to know exactly how
it comes to that prediction
thankfully this talk covers explainable
ai which puts the tools in your hands
to help you increase your model's
transparency
if you want to learn how to use
explainable ai and the what if tool to
better understand your models
make sure to add this one to your
playlist finally have you had a chance
to check out kaggle it's a fully
customizable notebook environment where
you can get access to all the code and
data you need
as well as access all sorts of learning
opportunities and competitions
this week also features a session
talking about how kaggle transitioned
from gpus to tpus so
check out that talk and get hands-on
with ml
to add these sessions to your digital
playlist check out the link
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us using the hashtag
google cloud next we'll see you in the
cloud
you